[Música]
estoy convencida que transformar la
realidad tiene que ver mucho con quiénes
somos y me voy a centrar básicamente a
nivel personal creo que para que se
pueda transformar la realidad
necesitamos centrarnos básicamente en
tres verbos importantes dos que son de
arranque y uno que nos va a llevar a la
transformación y esto tiene que estar
conjugado en primera persona
creo que la existencia es el centro de
toda transformación cuando nosotros
éramos niños cada uno de los que estamos
aquí para poder entender lo que era la
realidad tocábamos saboreábamos nos
caíamos y eso nos daba cuenta de la
existencia nos ubicaba en el aquí y el
ahora
y esto fue haciendo una cadena a lo
largo del tiempo y cada uno de ustedes
sin importar la edad que tenga ha sumado
a su existencia muchas experiencias que
nos han hecho cambiar
pero que hace la diferencia la
diferencia es precisamente la
persistencia cuando éramos niños
tratábamos de meter los objetos en
espacios que probablemente no cabían y
esto lo que hacía era alimentar nuestra
frustración hasta que nos dábamos cuenta
que había que girar el objeto y entonces
lo metíamos y ahí adquiríamos existencia
porque éramos conscientes de que
podíamos hacer las cosas y eso iba
transformando nuestra realidad y va poco
a poco llevándonos a cambiar antes de
avanzar quisiera preguntarles cuántos de
aquí saben nadar
muchas gracias no todos sabemos nadar
como sirenas y tritones como fueron
enseñados a nadar y los aventaron a la
alberca cuantos fueron aventados a la
alberca
eran métodos y eran métodos que
funcionaban con funcionaban con muchos
conmigo no funciona no funciona yo creo
que por eso no nado muy bien mi papá lo
que hizo fue aventarme a la segunda le
llamamos la segunda en el pueblo que me
tapaba y me decía nada 20 para acá y
pues nada y yo me hundía
hasta que de repente me dijo hazle como
los perritos entonces esa fue mi primera
lección de natación aviéntate y hablé
como en los perritos cuando llegué a
donde estaba el ya estaba yo he hecho un
mar de lágrimas y le decía no puedo no
puedo y me decía si puedes no sabes cómo
esa fue la primera lección de vida que
tuvo tuvo que ver con la trascendencia
yo fui consciente de mi existencia
porque me estaba hundiendo persistir en
la nada y transforme una capacidad que
no tenía de nada a poder nada entonces a
veces nuestra realidad es así se ve muy
obscura y hay una luz afuera
que nos hace entender que hay algo que
tiene que cambiar algo que no está como
quisiéramos
y de pronto contrastamos la realidad
afuera que no nos gusta pero tenemos el
lío interno y decimos con que empiezo
con arreglar la realidad de afuera o
realidad interna cuál de las dos
realidades me corresponde arreglar y en
muchos momentos de nuestra vida así como
estaba yo en la alberca de no puedo lo
que pasa es que no sabemos cómo no
tenemos claro cuál es la ruta que nos va
a llevar a poder saber cómo cambiar eso
que no nos gusta pongo un ejemplo los
que nos gustan los animales
quisiéramos que nadie los maltratar
que no patearon a los gatos o que no
tirarán a los perros oa las gatas por
ser hembras y decimos que hago una gran
campaña pero a lo mejor nuestra
capacidad nuestros recursos no nos dan
para eso y pensamos que el reto es
demasiado grande y entonces aquí yo digo
por qué no empezamos con el círculo
inmediato si a mí me gustan los animales
y yo puedo enseñar a mis sobrinos a los
niños que estén cerca de mí a mis amigos
a que no los maltraten estoy haciendo
una transformación a partir de mis
creencias con los que están en mi
círculo inmediato si de esos de mi
círculo inmediato 5 se convencen y hacen
exactamente lo mismo ya no voy a hacer
un a una sola persona y así vamos
replicando y replicando entonces
tendríamos que hacernos este recorrido
primero la frustración del no puedo
luego preguntarnos de verdad no puedo no
puedo cambiar en mi vida eso que no me
gusta
y después decir puedo
y ahí nos llevaría a ese como
y hacemos una pausa y esta pausa tiene
que ver con nuestra propia existencia
para que yo pueda cambiar algo en mi
realidad que no me gusta necesito hacer
un alto a veces hay cosas que no nos
gustan y está tan rápido lo que está
sucediendo que no hay oportunidad de
hacer un alto o creemos que no hay
oportunidad de hacer un alto y si no
hacemos un alto no podemos analizar
nuestra historia y ver quiénes hemos
sido y solo haciendo un alto y sabiendo
quienes hemos sido vamos a encontrar
esas pequeñas claves que nos van a
recordar que hemos podido y que hemos
trascendido en más de una ocasión que
hemos tras transformado esa realidad que
creíamos que no se podía cosas tan
simples aprender a andar en bicicleta
poder botar una pelota a mí me costó
mucho trabajo saltar la cuerda no sé si
a ustedes les gustó trabajo pero me
costó mucho trabajo saltar la cuerda y
cuando ya lo hacía con soltura
es a saltar la cuerda me sirvió para
poder cuando no pude seguir estudiando
en la universidad por falta de dinero
hacer un alto y decir qué puedo hacer
desde que tenía 15 años yo quería hacer
comunicóloga y trabaje para poder ser
comunicóloga para mi preparatoria entré
a la universidad y no pude obtener la
beca al 100% como yo quería
y dejé a mis compañeros de un grupo que
adoraba
y tuve que trabajar ocho meses para
poder ahorrar y juntar una colegiatura
en la universidad en la que estaba y
entonces me acordé que había aprendido a
saltar la cuerda que había aprendido a
nadar como perrito y dije lo que hay que
hacer es encontrar el como entre ella a
la universidad se me dio la oportunidad
de venirme a este lugar que yo no
conocía más que a mi marido dirige y
ahora qué voy a hacer en un lugar donde
no conozco a nadie no sé si voy a poder
a trabajar y regrese
pensar
por donde podía ir al asunto
recordé que debería de tener paciencia
como la paciencia que tienen todos
aquellos que siguen su propósito en la
vida
y el propósito el primer propósito es
existir entonces habría que encontrar
cómo existir en este espacio
más adelante tu oportunidad de entrar a
la universidad y cuando puedo lo
recuerdo yo entré a dar clases porque
firmé una servilleta en que me
comprometí a titularme ya dar clases y
como creo en las firmas y en la palabra
de honor pues empecé a dar clases y con
el primer grupo que tuve me frustré
terriblemente y dije esto no es lo mismo
saludo a un uno de los
alumnos que tuve este paco que fue de
los primeros que me hicieron pensar que
esto no era lo mío
y tuve la paciencia y entonces me di
cuenta
que tenían la resistencia y gracias a
ese primer grupo con el que yo me
frustré no por ellos sino porque yo no
sabía ser maestra
no eran ellos los del problema era yo
que no sabía ser maestra y que tenía que
aprender y que no se trataba de enseñar
al otro sino de ver cómo podían aprender
y eso hizo una transformación en mí a
veces uno piensa muy románticamente que
uno transforma a los alumnos pero no eso
me transformó a mí hizo un me obligó a
preguntarme ya resistir la frustración
que sentía para poder encontrar el cómo
hacerlo entonces nuevamente
es cuestionarse y pensar cómo hacerlo
quité a mi niña querida la creatividad
para mí la trascendencia y esta
transformación que uno hace de su propia
realidad no puede darse si no es a
partir de la creatividad porque porque
la creatividad nos da alternativas para
que podamos decidir y analizar si esto
que estoy viviendo es lo que quiero
vivir
hay una autora que se llama erika land o
una brasileña que tiene un libro que se
llama el vivir creativo que fue de los
primeros libros de creatividad con los
que yo venturosamente me encontré
y había una frase que decía más o menos
algo así quien ha sido creativo está
listo para morir fue una frase así que
me pegó en la cabeza y yo dije esto es
muy trascendente y yo dije por qué
porque si uno se ha mantenido en
contando constante transformación es
porque ha optado por muchos cambios a lo
largo de la vida intencionalmente y uno
ha hecho lo que quiere hacer
gracias a encontrar los caminos y esos
caminos te los da la creatividad te da
las respuestas te cuestiona te asusta no
hay cosas que te asuste más que lo nuevo
y seguimos en patrones comunes sin
querer cambiar porque es cómodo y porque
es seguro y la transformación tiene una
carga muy fuerte de incertidumbre y por
eso la paciencia es importante la
resistencia es importante y también la
creatividad y esto me lleva a una de mis
palabras favoritas
es la voluntad
no hay cosas más
trascendente e importante que la
voluntad que somos capaces de acumular
porque porque es esta voluntad las la
que nos va a mantener de pie y nos va a
hacer llegar a donde queremos llegar por
voluntad alguien gana un premio por
voluntad hay quien se titula por
voluntad hay quien persigue sus sueños
por voluntad estamos aquí alguien los
obligó a venir
están por voluntad
a nosotros nos obligaron a estar aquí no
estamos por voluntad pero es como se
acumula
mi mamá tenía un método medio extraño
para fortalecer la voluntad de sus tres
adolescentes
se le ocurrió que todas las mañanas a
las 3 de la mañana nos teníamos que
levantar y eran dos frascos un frasco
lleno de canicas y un frasco vacío y no
a cada adolescente nos dio un frasco y
nos dijo pónganlo en lo más alto que se
les ocurra y pues como uno no sabía de
qué se trataba el asunto lo pusimos en
lo más alto que se nos ocurrió
y entonces nos dijo a las 3 de la mañana
durante todo un año se tienen que
levantar a destapar un frasco y pasar
una canica al otro frasco y volverlo a
tapar
he de confesarles que había días en los
que no me quería levantar mi mamá nos
decía entonces te vas a tardar más de un
año porque tienes que completar los 365
días eso fue un entrenamiento muy fuerte
para fortalecer la voluntad y sumó
entonces paciencia resistencia
creatividad y voluntad cuatro cosas que
nos pueden llevar
a esta transformación
si no nos tenemos paciencia para irnos
equivocando e ir encontrando respuestas
si no tenemos resistencia a la
frustración cómo vamos a cambiar si a
las primeras de cambio nos estamos
frenando cómo vamos a cambiar
necesitamos encontrar nuestras
respuestas y por lo tanto hacer altos
para revisar nuestra historia que si
hemos logrado que no y vale la pena
yo no sé cantar y yo podría haberme
enfrascado en la frustración de querer
cantar
en público porque canto en privado o le
cantó al oído a mi marido puedo cantar
pues si se puede cantar pero feo pero ya
sé que yo no puedo hacer
cantante de ópera entonces no lo intento
que si puedo ser
pues puede escribir puedo cocinar puedo
estar en interacción con mis alumnos eso
me hace recordar un grupo de títeres que
hubo en la universidad y a ciertos
alumnos que eran de derecho y tenían que
inscribirse a un taller y se
inscribieron tarde y el único taller que
les tocó fue el nuestro de títeres y
ellos decían que estamos haciendo los
abogados en este taller de títeres y al
principio entraron con frustración mucha
frustración poco a poco fueron
descubriendo que estaban hablando en
público
que eran capaces de memorizar se grandes
textos
que impactaban en los otros que podían
trabajar en equipo esos abogados que
jamás pensaron que podían hacer títeres
interactuaron con su audiencia
y eso que parecía que no les servía para
nada les desarrollo habilidades que
necesitan los abogados entonces yo me
quedaría e invitaría a que sean
pacientes sean resistentes encuentren
alternativas para hacer lo que su
corazón y su cabeza les dice fortalezcan
su voluntad no con canicas encuentren
sus maneras
y transformen su realidad porque esa
realidad va a impactar en los otros
muchísimas gracias
[Música]